[Music]  hey there i'm the deep and while i'm  privileged to be one of the world's  greatest superheroes i'm even more  privileged today to announce my new  title as chief sustainability associate  at liquid death mountain water  scientists most of the dolphins i've  talked to say that by 2050 plastic  pollution will outweigh fish life pound  for pound in our oceans and that's why  liquid death is pure mountain water  comes in aluminum cans because they're  infinitely recyclable  [Music]  10 of all profits go to help ocean  plastic cleanup  that's pretty cool  [Music]  we can all be heroes by declaring death  to plastic  [Music]  and it burns when i breathe it's  refreshing to do good so please  keep our oceans beautiful  [Music]  you